thank you it'll go to my head
we can't have that we can't have it go
to my head thank you very much i really
do appreciate that and i appreciate you
also being on the side of optimism it
was a very strange week there's a lot of
good news
which i'm going to get to but it came
too late
to help the democrats from getting their
ass kicked all over the country in
off-year elections have you been
following that uh virginia was the big
one
the
terraria mcauliffe was the governor
it should have been an easy race lost to
glenn yonkin
have you nobody glenn younkin it sounds
like the scotch you buy it costco glenn
gwynyon
okay so
the big uh i've been saying this schools
are going to be the big
that what that's what happened with the
big issue was critical race theory being
taught in the schools we're going to
talk about it on the panel i'll just say
virginia people
the only race they want their kids to be
learning about is nascar that that seems
to be the message
now i think democrats should study
critical race theory uh which is the
theory that it's critical to win races
uh
and of course you know they're blaming
biden because you know his number is
taking everybody down that you know
they're already writing biden's obituary
it's political obituary uh the real one
they wrote years ago
buddy oh biden not another rough week i
got to say you know first of all all
over the country now conservatives think
it's so funny to say let's go brandon
have you followed this story there was a
nascar race and a driver named brandon
won the same day that the crowd was
chanting [ __ ] joe biden
and the announcer
either dumb or wanting to cover this up
said they're saying let's go brandon
so now airline pilots are saying it's a
big code word for [ __ ] biden so that was
bad then biden oh went to glasgow
scotland for the big summit meeting
gave a a moving speech uh saying that
the recent alarming news about melting
ice flows and natural disasters should
serve as a real wake-up call and then he
fell asleep
so
that didn't look go
no the the far left is right he's not
woken up
it's got to literally
literally be more work
his disapproval rating joe's was 36
not that far
long ago now it's up to 53 percent
and joe said you think that's bad you
should hear about this brandon guy
people really hate him
oh
but this is what's so weird about it the
actual news is pretty good the economy
is going through the roof we added 531
000 jobs in october that's a big number
for one month the dow
there was a book could the dow ever be
thirty six thousand now it is
the stock market's never been higher uh
we're out of afghanistan kovid's going
way down and they have a pill now
merck had it about a month ago now that
was going to stop 50 of this now pfizer
has one that says
we'll stop 90 percent
so we have a shot and we have a pill
could i please return to real life i
left the coffee maker on in my office
and
it's been since march of 2020.
no i think this pill is going to be a
real game changer although it's a it's
kind of a curveball to the imagination
people
uh because on the one hand it's endorsed
by the government so uh you know it will
take away your freedom
[Laughter]
on the other hand it's a pill so you can
grind it up and store it in your truck
speaking of trucks do you know who
lauren bobert is
she's one of the
new republican
republican uh people let's just say
there i think she's from colorado uh she
spoke out
this week made news she said no one
really needs
paid maternity leave because quote i
delivered one of my children in the
front seat of my truck
and she cut the umbilical cord by
slamming the door
this chick is rugged uh
and
this was at a wendy's drive-thru
and then she ordered nuggets for the
baby i'm telling you this
and not to be outdone marjorie taylor
green said when it's time for her to
give birth
she just crawls under the front porch
but speaking of paid maternity leave
democrats are this close
to passing their big bill and family
leave is added back in joe manchin was
objecting to that and uh kirsten cinema
she she's still deciding what what to go
as for halloween
she is hard to really
and uh this i love this did you see this
story there's been hundreds of q anon
followers are there q and on people here
everyone is welcome at my show
no no anyway if you are you will uh they
were camping out in dealey plaza dallas
because they believed jfk jr
son of the most iconic democrat ever
who died in a plane crash in 1999 was
going to return or maybe never died or
returned from the dead i don't know
to lead the republican party
or something like that
one of the parts of the theory was that
trump was going to be reinstated
uh-huh
and then he would make jfk jr his vice
president and then trump would step down
and jfk jr would be president who would
then appoint michael flynn to be vice
president
just like it says in our constitution
ladies and gentlemen that they're always
carrying around
that's up
so all that's gonna happen
and then jfk junior is gonna say you
know maybe next time we could meet
somewhere my father wasn't assassinated
is that
would that fit in
but they know who this jfk junior is
they i have this is i'm not making this
up they have the i'll show you the
picture this is the person they say
is jfk junior now
dead ringer isn't he what isn't he a
dead
[Applause]
and by the way i'm really river phoenix
anyway
you